26 ans 1 m 80 pour 66 kg gallus coulon
est aujourd'hui l'un des meilleurs
boxeurs en ile de france dans la
catégorie des poids moyens le trappistes
qui s'entraîne avec la team farruggia
ils ont quoi commencé la boxe à 17 ans
après être passé par le football n'était
plus sur la solitaire du tips
individualiste donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas me tourner vers la boxe
parce que c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours attiré en regardant les vidéos
de rookie mal tyson et c'est donc une
fille dit avec mon ami en jour on lave
aussi une bosse il avait marre du
football donc conseillé de tout diriger
vers la salle d'elancourt
après avoir combattu en amateur gay du
secouement s'est lancé en professionnel
en 2012 sous les conseils de son mentor
le coach jean guy farrugia qui l'a pris
sous son aile dès son arrivée au club
c'est quelqu'un qui écoute bien après à
chaque mockler à haut niveau et jamais
il ya toujours des choses on n'est pas
d'accord
bienvenue c'est quand même un peu de
vent aujourd'hui le boxeur affiche un
bilan de 6 victoires 7 défaites et un
nul le stratège participera à la finale
du tournoi de france ce vendredi 4
novembre à cahors contre ma citation de
fontenay sous bois pour préparer ce
combat gaydu s'entraîne depuis septembre
et a mis les gants avec des sparring
partner en normandie en ile de france et
préparation se passe est qui le propulse
en favori de la rencontre
c'est pas important d'être favori je
pense après sûrement onu aux yeux de
certaines personnes peut-être ne sais
pas mais en tout cas l'adversaire il est
bien là il en finale il n'est pas là par
hasard donc
maintenant on a fait la préparation avec
tanguay qu'il fallait pour être prêt le
jour j
donc maintenant à moi de savoir chez mes
qualités je sais ce que j'ai à faire
pour partir et revenir avec la victoire
s'il ya du school on remporte son combat
vendredi le trappistes visera un titre
de champion de france dans les prochains
mois avec son club de coeur la team
farooq shah